I was very serious the other day when I
said that we all need to dress up as our
own versions of Barbie no after watching
the Barbie movie we couldn't resist
creating our own Barbie wing costume
you're not allowed to dress up as Barbie
or the flash or baby Yoda this year as
if you do well union bosses consider you
a scab sag after released guidance last
week urging its currently striking
members and all those who stand in
solidarity with them to avoid character
costumes that reference film and TV now
some Hollywood stars aren't happy Ryan
Reynolds joked that he couldn't wait to
scream at his 8-year-old and Mandy Moore
called the fun killing suggestion a
distraction finally the union clarified
that the costume guidance does not apply
to kids but expect even some adults will
be feeling the kenergy what have you
done what are you
wearing don't question it just roll with
it tiny baby